you could check this man out on the
stand-up comedy circuit just next week
in Phoenix Arizona
stand up live on December 28th and 30th
if you're in Oxnard California home of
the Dallas Cowboys training camp the
18th through 21st at levity live you can
get tickets available that Adam ray
comedy calm and the co-host of the about
last night podcast as well Adam right
here on the show Jose thank you for the
plug you know Brockman who you know very
well out there has never seen about last
night
you never listen to my podcast no he's
never seen the movie or the movie movie
about last night movie
Wow idea have you seen Air Bud 6
everybody I've not seen here about 6 do
you need to see the first 5 air buds in
order to understand it I don't either
guy that says you don't you know a
naysayer huh no I feel like but
everybody I mean I think I saw the first
2 legitimately I don't know in theaters
but where I was like genuinely pumped to
be like you know everyone said this dog
couldn't play ping-pong I would like to
be the one to know I'm gonna be the one
to say nay to them yeah I think you have
to I think yeah so now I'm looking at
the s on your lid yeah this I heard
Mariners even though we lost Mariner
right there
yeah this is old-school and I think this
is what you do as a fan when you lose
out on a game changing player Oh Sean II
oh Sahni Otani Otani
yeah see I don't care that's that was
like you're pissed at the guy that you
don't even know his name didn't sign
with you that's fandom right there by
the way it really is and you know at
this point too like we needed somebody
like that to really help ticket sales
and I would like to take this moment to
tell des Poteau or GM like hey where's
my Depot tow camera their total cam is
right there there we go straight yeah
there we go yeah look I think it's time
we got maybe a small window with some of
these guys and you're trying to like go
for pictures you're like we don't need
any more hitters you're wrong on that
and this is what I think this season
should be let's bring back some of the
old guys let's break this is a bring
back Buhner campaign okay put him in
right field
oh he can't run oh do we care not really
dude I'm trying to go see Buhner live
okay and he's not doing a one-man show
anymore or I don't know if he ever was
sooner live is the worst medal out of
all time the producers of Sesame Street
Live he just shapes kids head sooner was
great man he was one of the best and and
also one of the best punchlines in the
history of Seinfeld when when when went
Costanza's dad meets George Steinbrenner
in the first George is potentially dead
yeah and George's dad says to Steiner
what the hell'd you trade Jay Buhner for
and then Larry David's voice saying
baseball people my baseball people said
Ken Phelps Phelps oh my god who by the
way was there when they yeah when the S
was on the hat that you have
it's amazing to think that how close the
Mariners like we would have been Seattle
was for losing two franchises like the
Mariners had we not had that 95 season
they already apparently had Tampa Bay
Mariner apparel printed up huh and that
would have been devastating I mean
losing the Mariners and the Sonics like
what was it Key Arena supposedly maybe
getting somebody back in hockey or
hopefully hockey I think is is more
likely the NBA should happen because
there's only so many super jerseys I can
buy and I love the WNBA but it's not
what I grew up on I grew up on Michael
cage and Detlef Schrempf looking to open
a shrimp you know like at eat like a
line of treat at Friday's shrimps and if
you can pronounce it and what's wrong
did you read free appetizer you serve
it's shrimps whatever you want and this
is the main question we get when people
walk in because they go what is this
place yeah is it a lady footlocker
spin-off or is it a or is it a
Applebee's light you can get anything
you can get a lot of milkshakes okay um
a lot of like turkey Meat Loaf's
okay flat tops flat tops you have a
barber shop oh yeah dude shrimp did have
a nice set of he's a good-looking team
by the way your guys just talk about
Enberg was really it was perfect guy he
was no joke probably my top two favorite
commentators of all time especially
because the MBA is my favorite sport and
and growing up when the Sonics got a lot
of airplay he was the guy for all the
playoffs man even he was a guy who
called when Dikembe upset my SuperSonics
and the eight seeds over the one in 94 a
nugget
right other than other than my parents
divorced thanks for bringing that up
that was the worst day of my life same
matumbo hold tombow like literally like
even if I'd find out my parents got
divorced with the Pitamber was hold the
bond was like and and Lance and put in
are no longer together I would've been
like I don't care man like you just beat
Kemp and he was waving in two fingers
with the fingers like yeah they don't
love each other anymore but I mean a
joke about know that actually something
that obviously was a blow if matumbo
came out to told any kid that his
parents and he just he doesn't even say
anything you just know that it's over
well no this large 7-foot man with a
waving a finger to let me know about my
parents divorced but and durable but
Enberg was the man through all that and
so and it made it you know that much
more special to see your home team on
the atom right here on the Rich Eisen
show speaking of Larry Davis yeah we're
on an episode of curve you played one of
the uber drivers yeah this would came up
yesterday I was with a buddy of mine who
was trying to put his credit card
information in uber app and it wasn't
taken he right and all pissed off I'm
like well maybe your ratings terrible we
had conversation about the uber rating
line from from curb yeah
this year what was that like being on
the set dude it was you were the scene
with him flat-out seen with him I've
seen and it's like it was only a minute
long scene which you know I think every
actor in like you know editing is out of
control you know and we had so many
funny riffs I mean you know everything's
improvised
we have a couple nuggets of like we need
to hit these beats like at one point
Larry's gonna ask you what his rating is
you Tomi's are one that's basically it
and the rest is just open forum for
funny and you know in the audition I
went in twice it once as me once with an
accent and made him just laugh a ton and
he's behind me and and you know I it's
my favorite show so I've watched so much
I kind of knew how to build a fight you
know and like give him kind of nugget to
funny and once he takes someone runs
with it then I know I can and jump in
and we maybe did 9 10 takes and they
were all pretty good and then like the
last few we're I think pretty
exceptional and I walked away being like
I think they got enough to really cut
some but you know there was we had a
great fight that it built to but even
getting a minute
time with them is amazing it's pretty
cool it's great and then you're you can
play a believable character from what I
heard yeah roast of David Ortiz the
House of Blues in Boston that has never
made a lot of error made Nessun was
gonna air kind of like an hour cut down
and when they went back and looked at
the footage it was so blue and x-rated
they couldn't air it back but you play
that's me you got in a full holy let's
me gray hair
get up yeah in a Yankee Jersey yeah so I
was gonna I'm not a big you know I'm not
a roast comic like I definitely do a lot
of crowd work in my standup better and
you know so much so that I can handle
you know I think anything at this point
and if but I was trying to kill people
with kindness and then if I have to slam
them and really take care of things yeah
well after a while at that point the
audience is on my side to to take care
of it but but um so when I got asked to
do it I was like well maybe I can do it
as a character you know it's on MADtv
and that's just kind of my my thing and
I'll be more comfortable to roast people
that way make fun of a Big Papi if he
doesn't know who I am so you played an
old and older talking organic you so I
flew the woman who did she did a makeup
on SNL in the 90s and then this new
season of Mad TV and and so I can you
make me unrecognizable like I don't know
67 year old Yankees fan and I'll feel
better to kind of make fun of these guys
and you know I laid it on Dustin Pedroia
pretty hard and like you know my jokes
we're just you know Dustin Pedroia is uh
you know his natural position is second
base but or his real position is second
base but let's let's be honest his
natural position is dancing next to a
pot of gold at the end of a rainbow and
then like you know Dustin looks like a
kid whose dad or a dad whose parents
call him by his first name you know like
kids it's time for bed you know Fu
Dustin and I later on pretty hard and
then you turn over to Josh wolf and he
was like dude who is this old man like I
mean this guy's such pissed yeah he was
like he's a dick and and and I was like
and Josh like no he's my buddy Adam he's
a comedian and and then we started
becoming Twitter friends and now he's
like man I wanted to come see you do
stand-up and the last two times we
messaged he said he was out of town for
a vacation and his anniversary and I'm
like dude just tell me you don't want to
see me cuz these excuses are really
starting to get lame Oh family I'm there
you know no no you're good dude we'll
hang out soon yeah Quiznos careful
an Arizona - are you really nope enjoy
is the minute you know and and he can
really take a JIT like some you hear
some of these athletes and see him -
that just can't laugh at themselves but
uh a hobby - I mean I said he was like
the Dominican Babe Ruth or no the DEA
and he looks like he ate all the baby
Ruths
I'm butchering the joke no it says why
nothin didn't know I was at a baseball
Writers Association dinner bill chef -
they commedia you know who's a Letterman
writer for so many years he laid waste
the entire day is filled with the
Yankees and said the joke that Chuck
Knobloch man he said his aim is so bad
we should set him to Cuba to overthrow
Castro Steinbrenner was on the dais and
Clemens and Torre and Jeter and cone and
Wells all of them were on a dais and
Torre sit next to Steinbrenner
stone-faced
and the other guys were on the other
side of the dais like put their hands
over their mouth like diving for cover
underneath the table no oh they love oh
they did but they couldn't they couldn't
act like it some of these guys don't
have a sense of humor yeah I wish they
would aired it but there was so much you
know they really slammed grogg teams he
did that I heard that right it was you
know he was the most clickable bait you
know if they Blacks and Jews it would've
been like who Aaron and his set was so
tame compared to everyone look roaster
blue that's the way it should work
exactly at Adam rate comedy on Twitter I
want to take a break come back I don't
take some of these phone calls oh yeah
you ever take on whether diehards at
Christmas moving or not or if you do who
can hold it I don't think it is I think
it's not it's not I've got by the way
let's take a break coming back in 60
seconds I have the end of this
conversation Jase this is going to be
the end we're going to end the
conversation I have a piece of
information that will end it it's like
saying lethal weapons a Chanukah movie
correct right yeah yes yes we'll reveal
our responses to the Friday pitch rich
question of names of college bowl games
rejected because they were too long
that's coming up next here on the Rich
Eisen show
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show Adam
ray comedian Adam ray actor Adam Reyes
chilling out with us here on the program
the poll question as it currently stands
brought to you by HGTV Chris Brockman go
for it yeah it's die hard a Christmas
movie sorry guys
63% are on the good guy team me yes mmm
tired of Christmas movie Dave in New
York you're here on the show what's up
Dave oh what an honor it is to talk with
you thank you Dave thanks Dave no rich
yeah I'm here too man
I'm started watching you I know you're
short but I started watching you when
you're as Dan Cathy and then I just
followed you over on to your own show
and a well deserved show thank you
really proud Dan Patrick and his crew
are awesome but you guys you're holding
your own great show thanks Dave all of
the DP crew as well thanks for saying
welcome so anyways
yes die hard is a Christmas show what
are you it a Christmas show Dave what
are you on right now it's not a show
like a weekly show sorry
movie about Christmas dad what did you
say it's a movie about Christmas why is
it a do Christmas movie Dave okay
because it's focused around Christmas
it's a feeling it's more of how people
from all different walks of life you
look at Christmas and I think everybody
in the world could relate to that Dave I
appreciate your call and what you said
about this show I'm gonna have to
respectfully disagree with you yeah I'm
just gonna have to disagree with you
disrespectfully because I don't think
it's a Christmas movie it is not a
Christmas well there's there's too much
action what you know no Cushi movies are
have you seen the ABC Family movies with
like Mario Lopez and Shaggy and Candace
Cameron where it's like Jared was only
seven and loved Christmas more than
anything and then his best friend
through his chinchilla and the fire and
Santa helped him get it back get a new
chin [ __ ] like that's a Christmas movie
yes yeah anyway
I'd go a miracle on 34th Street totally
you know if Mario Lopez is in it it's
probably Holliday Hans Gruber is not in
it's a wonderful life no thank you
that's correct argue that he's the guy
who shuts down
Bailey savings in one Newton in Richmond
Virginia you are here on the Rich Eisen
show what's up Newton same to the world
I don't believe it's a Christmas movie
but here's some points that shoot holes
in that theory and a small couple of
Corrections okay small correction it
wasn't a movie about terrorists taking
over a building it was a movie about a
heist they were stealing okay all right
secondly if you put the theory of if you
take the Christmas element out of it
will it still be a movie well
unfortunately we have to say you can't
because the premise was that John was on
his way back to see his family and his
maybe ex-wife because they live divorced
yet and the whole theme of him visiting
a Christmas and the spirit of Christmas
around that is D way to some people who
like daddy Christmas on some level a
Christmas movie and it kind of I hope
you have that monologue tattooed on your
lower back because that is a very
passionate state contortion is what I do
that's what everybody's been trying to
contort to make it a Christmas movie I'm
going I'm going endless I know where
you're going okay
diehard supposed Christmas move of
course fan that has no Christmas images
on its movie poster whatsoever was
released on July 15th
thank you 1988 egg Willie weekend if it
is a Christmas movie in the eyes of the
filmmakers and the studio they do not
release it after July 4th case in point
in the same month as Joe
you're right because film studios have a
great track record of winter bobbies
movie style right you are not releasing
you're releasing an action movie in the
summer not a Christmas movie yeah and
this is what you were releasing a
Christmas movie in December why would
you release an action set around
Christmas in July that's just bad on the
movie producers and the film studio
speaking of which how come we don't have
any like when somebody said home alone
is an invasion movie this is a Christmas
movie which I loved like how we never
get Hanukkah is the backdrop to any of
these stories like Kevin McCallister
could have yeah missed the flight they
were going to see Gloria and Max you
know over ha I'm Steen yeah and then I
was home alone he's like how am I gonna
light the menorah all by myself you know
only six candles you know what you know
yeah they could have been and instead of
a Christmas story with a Red Ryder rifle
it could have been a Passover story with
with a matzah brei yeah no I'm just I'm
just spitballing but you're also exactly
right let's get to our pitch Friday
results shall we do that okay here on
the Rich Eisen show every single week we
have this fun endeavor with our friends
at Funny or Die where we give away an
invitation to their app the pitch app
that is writers and comics only they pay
for jokes on there so you can start a
career in writing jokes and getting paid
for it I hear that George my stepdad
there you go your puns have a place to
live now there we go
and this week's thread that we asked you
to give your best answer to the hashtag
of pitch rich the pitch Friday topic
college football bowl games that were
rejected for being too long and Adam Ray
is sitting right next to us with the
drumroll please
number five
the nighttime sniffling sneezing
coughing aching stuffy had fever so you
can rest bowl number four the Jason if
you're watching this I spent all your
savings on the naming rights to this
game and I'm leaving you bowl number
three the hey why don't you play another
somebody done somebody wrong song
Cromartie family Bowl presented by
Antonio Jersey Karis Marie Leilani Tyler
J Julian Jagger Antonio jr. deja Alonso
and London Cromartie game banana Bow Wow
that's cool man
Rogers in Los Angeles California that's
a playground I know right there I kind
of dig that Wow
the listener viewer submission the the
the pitch submission and invitation goes
to Ryan Jacobs at the underscore Ryan
Jacobs gave you the Derek Zoolander Bowl
for teams who can't play good and also
can't read good but also want to play in
a bowl game and other stuff too good
ballgame I'm a fan of many Zoolander
ergo Zoolander reference gets somebody a
pitch app invitation there you go thanks
for coming on brother this was the blast
thank you for having any time come on
back thank you buddy
for more Rich Eisen show tuned to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the
doesn't show up